For a vast number of complicated reasons.
Milton has invited for 350 years now,
uh,
uniquely violent.
And I do think it's a violent response to the particular question of his value
as a,
as a poet.
And the violence I think of this reaction is due in large part to our tendency
to think of Milton and,
uh,
and of Milton's work in terms of the category of power.
So I've given this first lecture a title,
the title being Milton Power and the power of Milton because any introduction to
Milton has to confront the longstanding conviction and English letters of
Milton's power or his strength as a,
as a poet.
And it's practically impossible to begin to reading of Milton without the burden
of,
of innumerable prejudices and preconceptions.
Milton's reputation always proceeds him.
And in fact,
that's always been the case,
even in his lifetime.
And even if we've heard of nothing of Milton,
the poet or nothing of Milton the man,
we're certainly of course likely to have heard of,
of Adam and eve in of the story of Garden of Eden.
So,
and so it's especially difficult,
uh,
to read paradise lost without bringing to it some sense of the power of the,
of the religious problems,
the theological and ethical problems that,
that story seems so powerfully to set out to address.
Now,
readers,
readers of English literature talk about Milton very differently from the way
they talk about other other writers.
Historically,
it has not been a pleasure or wit or,
or beauty that have been associated with the experience of Reading Milton.
Those are the categories of value that we tend to associate or to affiliate with
our other favorite writers,
writers as diverse as a,
as,
as Shakespeare and uh,
Virginia Woolf for example.
But in a,
in our collective cultural consciousness,
if there's such a thing,
uh,
whether we like him or not,
we tend to think of Milton.
We tend to think of John Milton is powerful and the reasons for this coupling of
the of the name Milton and have this idea or the metaphor of power I think are
worth looking into.
Power is a conceptual category that Milton bruited on and,
and,
and cultivated his entire writing life from a very early age.
Milton nursed the image of himself as a powerful poet and in Milton we have a
man who was able to state now just think about this for a moment.
It's,
I take this to be an absolutely remarkable fact.
We have in Milton a man who was able to state categorically in his early
twenties,
so just a few years older than you are now,
that the epic poem that he would not even begin writing for another 25 years
would become an unforgettable work of English literature.
Milton anticipated and lovingly invested his,
uh,
all of his in his future literary power and his future literary fame.
He anticipated this power much as his father,
that reasonably well to do banker might have a anticipated long term earnings
from a particularly risky business venture.
And in Milton's case,
the,
this,
this investment in power paid off,
Milton would come to feel,
would eventually come to feel so comfortable with the,
with the mantle of power that he was able to do much more than simply rewrite
the first,
the first books of the Bible,
which is of course one of the things that he accomplished and paradise lost.
And that is itself,
no,
no mean undertaking.
By the end of his life,
though,
Milton would in effect try to rewrite everything.
After he'd published all of his major poems,
he,
he began publishing a spate of works that attempted to recreate British culture
from the ground up.
He,
uh,
he invented his own system of,
of philosophical logic.
He published a treatise that he had written earlier on,
on grammar,
inventing his own system for the understanding and the learning of the,
of the Latin language.
He wrote a long and detailed history of Britain attempting to create the meaning
of that little island that,
that he always assumed was God's chosen,
chosen nation.
And finally,
and probably four more Milton most important,
uh,
Milton wrote a theology and inventing in effect his own religion.
And Milton's,
Milton's Protestantism looks like it looks like no one else's.
Since,
uh,
before our sense there,
there's a real sense,
I think in which Milton wanted to recreate all of western culture at or to
recreate all of western culture in his own image.
And regardless of what we think of the success of that example or of the appeal
of the attempt to do such a thing,
the amazing thing I think is that Milton felt so empowered even to embark on
such an enormous project.
And readers and readers of Milton ever since have had to confront not just
Milton's writing,
but this unspeakable sense of empowerment that that underlies,
um,
at just about everything that Milton rights.
And so it,
it seems to me that a useful introduction to the poetry of Milton would be a
look at some of the various various types of power that Milton imagines in his
work and,
and some of the types of power that literary history has,
has tended to confer upon,
uh,
upon Milton.
The man,
the image of Milton,
the man,
and of Milton's Milton's writing.
Now probably the form of power that,
that we most readily associate with a,
with John Milton involves his position at the dead center of the English
Literary Canon.
Milton is,
this,
is this,
this is,
this goes beyond questioning.
He's an object of worship by British and American institutions of higher
education.
And,
uh,
my guess is that uh,
many of you have failed.
A few of you have failed to observe that it's practically impossible to graduate
from Yale with a bachelor of arts in English without having read paradise lost
either an English one 25 or,
or ds lit or in fact,
and of course just like this one.
This for you.
Some of this will be this,
this is the course.
And uh,
and you,
those of you who are taking this course because you have to,
uh,
you have to take one of the pre 18 hundreds and Milton is one of those.
Um,
you are more than entitled to ask why the poet,
this poet Milton is exercising this institutional sway over you as you go about
choosing your courses or perhaps you experience your courses in some way as
having been chosen for him.
It would be utterly inadequate for us to account for this institutional.
And it's a real institutional power that Milton holds over us by stating,
uh,
blandly that Milton is the greatest,
the greatest English poet.
That's the easy answer obviously.
And of course it's not,
it's not untrue,
but,
but uh,
we can do better than that and we can anatomize some of the forms of power that
have been most commonly attributed to this greatest to this greatest English
poet.
There was first the,
um,
the understandable aesthetic power,
the power of the beauty of Milton's Milton's verse that a,
an aesthetic power that's often thought or felt to in here somewhere in the
poetry itself.
And in fact for,
for,
for readers of paradise lost.
And this has been an experience now for a few hundred years.
It does often seem as if there were some mysterious life force,
a pulsating through Milton's dense and driving lines of,
of unrivaled.
I am big pentameter and paradise lost.
Then now there's also the power.
There's also the power of that Milton himself claimed was behind the poetry of
paradise,
lost Milton insistent and it's completely possible that he might actually have
believed that God himself w was responsible for composing the poetry of
Paradise.
Lost that Milton Milton,
John Milton was merely the conduit for God's first serious attempt at a,
at an epic poem.
And so we have,
in this perspective,
we have an image of the awesome power of the deity himself.
Fun during a way behind every jot and tittle of,
of,
of Milton's great epic.
But for Milton's,
Milton's contemporaries in the 17th century,
Milton's power really wasn't at all aesthetic or,
or even religious in nature.
Milton Milton's pro power was primarily seen as social and political and
cultural.
Milton and this is a,
a wildly anachronistic use of terms,
but it's,
there's,
there's nonetheless,
uh,
a lot of sense to it.
Milton was essentially a left wing political radical,
and it was widely feared by his more timid contemporaries that,
that his writings would seduce,
seduce his readers into rejecting a good old fashion,
traditional religious and social values.
And,
and there was a,
there's a lot of validity to that contemporary cultural fear.
Uh,
Milton was,
Milton was a revolutionary.
He was responsible for writing the first justification for an armed rebellion
against the legitimate monarch.
Uh,
the first to publish such a work in essentially in all of Europe.
Um,
Milton actually wrote that it was the duty,
not just the right,
but the duty of a nation to rise up and dethrone dethrone through execution and
unjust and legitimate,
though legitimate king.
And Milton in fact,
was largely responsible,
responsible in a cultural sense for the fact that the armed rebellion of England
civil war,
what we call,
what we think of as the Puritan Revolution,
actually led to the execution,
the execution by decapitation of England's monarch,
Charles the first in 1649.
And on top of all of this political revolution,
the political radicalism,
Milton was one of the first intellectuals in Europe to speak out in favor,
not only of a,
of divorce.
Milton argued for the,
the right to divorce on grounds of in compatibility,
but also,
um,
he argued,
he argued in favor of the right to a plural marriage or polygamy.
He was branded as a radical and dangerous debunker of traditional Christian
family values.
And now,
many of you know that Milton in his later years was blind and the fact of his
blindness was in his own day,
frequently cited by contemporary preachers,
men at the pulpit as an example of exactly how God punishes those who dare to
write against the king or those who dare to write against the institution of
marriage or the family and Milton's power.
For so many of these contemporaries was,
was,
was seen as palpably destructive and,
and,
and truly frightening.
Obviously.
I,
it goes without saying that today the assessment of Milton is some kind of
imminent social threat,
um,
or some sort of social force in terms of his,
uh,
the radical nature of political power that has taken a sharp turn.
Milton is much more likely imagined to wield.
And if,
if you have any sense of what the mythology surrounding Milton is,
you would have to agree with this.
Milton's much more likely to imagine to be imagined to wheel to socially
conservative power over his readers and the,
in the debates ranging,
uh,
for the last 30 years or so over the value of traditional pedagogy and on over
the value of canonical reading lists.
Milton is always cited in variably cited as the canons most stalwart,
a representative of oppressive religious and social values.
And there's,
there's no question.
Milton is the dead white male poet,
uh,
par exsalonce in English letters certainly.
And his poetry works,
at least from this point of view,
his poetry works to solidify those dead white male values,
whatever those are in the unsuspecting minds of his readers,
none of whom,
obviously our dad and many have and many of whom are neither white nor nor male.
Milton's Milton's power from this perspective of the radical,
the radical cultural critique is really not so different from the power of the,
of the late Jerry Falwell or,
or,
or some someone like rush Limbaugh.
Um,
there,
there's something insidious and culturally,
uh,
malicious and powerful about the social conservatism of,
of what is thought to be his voice.
Now this more or less,
this is the contemporary picture of John Milton and this more or less
contemporary picture of Milton as the,
as a powerful force of conservatism derives in large part,
uh,
from,
from the English writer Virginia Wolfe who was writing,
uh,
who wrote for a few decades but wrote about Milton during the 1920s.
And it's Wolff's image that's probably the one that's most firmly rooted in the
minds of Milton's readers today for Virginia Woolf,
especially in a room of one zone,
the dead writer Milton exercises an active power and active power at the present
moment as he forces his female readers to accept their subordinate place in
society and the text of Milton and especially a paradise lost,
therefore has to be seen as an active,
a persistently malignant conveyor of,
of patriarchal oppression.
Now like all like all judgments of literary value and literary power and force,
the,
the 20th century feminist evaluation of Milton,
Virginia Woolf's has a,
has a complicated and long,
long prehistory and it's worth their while to look briefly at some of the
complicated steps by which an evaluation like Virginia Woolf sexually comes into
being.
So let me,
let me take you back.
This is,
you can,
you can now look at your handouts.
Let me take you back to the 17th century up to the very beginning of the
literary reception of John Milton.
So Milton who had died and who died in 1674 had established himself as a great
English poet within 20,
within 20 or so years of his death.
And so as early as the late 17th century,
Milton had already entered what we think of as the English literary cannon.
He was for many of his younger contemporaries.
He was a canonical authority whose wisdom,
whose mere opinions could be cited as proof,
as some sort of indisputable evidence for one,
one position or another.
And an an an an extraordinarily ambitious poet like Milton naturally derived,
uh,
a great deal of satisfaction.
I'm convinced in his own lifetime in anticipating just this kind of posthumous
respect and worship,
um,
the,
the fantasy of his fellow Englishman quoting him as an authority much as he
himself had for so many decades a quoted scripture.
Now,
one of the earliest,
and this,
I think this is a remarkable fact,
one of the earliest citations of paradise lost that actually appears in print in
the 17th century comes from the,
the pro feminist writer lady married cuddling and Chudleigh dared to argue.
And that's an amazing argument.
In a given the time and 1699 Chudleigh,
he argued that a man that a woman rather could be considered and should be
considered as excellent a creature as a man,
that women might actually be as ontologically valuable as as men.
And in making such a point,
chudleigh naturally had to confront the,
as,
as writers have a for Millennia Chudleigh he had to confront the problem of this
scriptural account of the priority of the sexes.
This suggestion that you can,
that many readers extract from the book of Genesis in the Bible,
that the initial creation of the male of the species,
Adam,
seems to establish the privileged,
the privileged drank of the entire male sex.
And so [inaudible] attempts to demonstrate,
and this is the passage at the top of top of the handout,
Chadley attempts to demonstrate that the genesis story of Adam and Eve
establishes no such thing.
Uh,
she writes,
woman's being created last will not be a very great argument to debase the
dignity of the female sex.
If some of the men ownness,
she continues to is more likely to be true.
The Great Milton a grave author brings in Adam the speaking to eve and paradise
lost and then she quotes Adam speaking to eve.
Oh fairest of creation.
Last and best of all God's works and the Great Milton can be invoked invoked
here because he has already been established as a,
as an authority,
a,
he's already been established as a figure who's very word possesses something
like an indisputable cultural power.
And so it was a very grave author.
This is what Chablis is implying.
Milton can tell us something potentially true about the priority of the sexes of
course.
And you know this to be the case from your own,
uh,
your,
your own writing of,
of,
of papers for in the English department.
Um,
like,
like any literary critic who ever tried to write an analysis of anything,
uh,
chudleigh he has no choice but to nudge the lines that she's quoting out of
context.
And it is,
it's,
it's been said that to quote anybody is necessarily to misrepresent him.
And,
uh,
this fact is obviously a very good thing for lady Mary Chad Leeson's.
Milton would certainly not himself have wanted to suggest that women are
superior to men.
Milton in fact,
soon goes on in paradise lost.
Um,
and then right after this very passage that she cites Milton,
the narrator be rates Adam for his overvaluation of his wife through the
character of the Archangel Rafiel [inaudible].
I think this is one of the great ironies of,
of English literary history.
Certainly in the reception of of the poet Milton that one of the very first
published published discussions of Milton's epic attempts to enlist John Milton
as a,
as a proponent of feminism.
Now,
we don't have to be overly concerned here with,
with what I take to be chug these generous,
generous oversight of Milton's,
uh,
generally sexist bias.
Uh,
what's important for our immediate purposes is her identification of Milton as a
cultural authority.
He's a literary power,
a figure who can be called upon to supply the,
the voice of,
of traditions,
uh,
itself.
He can be called upon,
in fact,
exactly as he is by lady Mary here.
He can be called upon to contradict scripture and it's,
and it's this power to contradict the word of God that makes Milton a force that
makes Milton a force then,
which it's hard to imagine anything more powerful.
Now,
as you can see from the handout,
Milton is discussed in a very different manner a year later and a work published
by Mary astral in in 1700 and in a,
in an even more remarkably feminist,
a remarkable cry for the liberation of women from what she describes and
characterizes as domestic oppression.
Um,
astral writes,
the following,
patients and submission are the only comforts that are left to a poor people who
grown under tyranny unless they are strong enough to break the yolk.
Not Milton himself would cry up liberty to poor female slaves or plead for the
lawfulness or resisting a private tyranny.
So Milton,
for,
for Astellas,
hardly the embodiment of orthodoxy that he is for Lady Mary Juggling Four for
Asto.
Milton remains this,
the subversive revolutionary whose treatises against the tyranny of the Stuart
monarchy,
whose treatise is against the tyranny of Charles.
The first established his reputation as a,
as a liberator,
a liberator of all of the oppressed and enslaved citizens of England.
And that's that,
that's Milton's rhetoric,
uh,
that,
that rhetoric belongs to Milton himself,
but as still resents of course,
Milton here and what she resents is the limitation of his subversiveness.
Um,
he refused to extend his critique of tyranny in the political realm to a
critique of man's domestic tyranny over woman in the,
in the private realm and the domestic sphere.
It's as if,
uh,
Mary Astellas saying what Milton was on the right track.
He simply didn't go far enough.
He didn't extend the logic of his position.
Now Milton's,
now it has to be said that Marianne [inaudible] image of Milton is probably the
product of a much closer reading of paradise lost,
um,
than,
than lady Mary Chumley's was,
uh,
Asil certainly seems to have noticed.
Milton's notorious and of course,
deplorable line and Paradise lost about God,
about God's creation of Adam and eve.
He forgot,
only she for God in him.
A Milton's narrator tells us of God's creation of Adam and eve and,
and Mary Astellas clearly responding to this and understatement points to a
persistent worry.
And it's a worry,
um,
that that exists even now in the 21st century.
Um,
about the nature of Milton's power.
Is this guy a revolutionary or is he a reactionary and,
and an astral distinguishes Milton's cry against political tyranny from her own
critique,
her own cry against a patriarchal tyranny.
And,
and in making this dis,
in making this distinction,
she's exposing something.
Um,
the,
that I take to be extremely interesting,
she's exposing the uncomfortable affinity between two competing equally
progressive social movements and what we,
and you'll,
and you'll see this phenomenon,
uh,
manifest itself,
through throughout your reading of,
uh,
of Milton.
I'm convinced.
And what we see here is the strange proximity and it's often a very
uncomfortable proximity of Milton's rhetoric of political liberation to the pro
feminist rhetoric of domestic liberation that is just beginning to emerge at the
end of the 17th century.
Now in the middle years of the 17th century during the English revolution,
but saw the execution of the king and saw the establishment of a non monarchic
Republican government.
Milton had practically invented the formal language,
the literary language of insubordination.
He developed an entire vocabulary,
a rhetoric of,
of righteous disobedience,
of,
of resistance,
of protest and revolution.
And,
and I think it's a measure of the power of Milton's anti tyrannical language
that,
that it can be used against Milton himself.
A writer like Mary Asto can employ Milton's revolutionary rhetoric to advance
the cause,
to which John Milton himself would of course have had difficulty subscribing,
that the dead Milton could exercise a social power that had nothing whatsoever
to do with the living Milton's own social own social views.
Now we'll fast forward a couple of centuries and look at Virginia Woolf and then
by the time we get to wolf in the early part of the 20th century,
Milton has come to be associated with essentially all of these ways of thinking
about power.
However contradictory they are.
Um,
uh,
he's the very voice of traditional wisdom for some as he was for lady Mary each
huddling and he's the voice of political subversiveness for others as he was
from Ariosto.
Um,
he's the friend of women everywhere,
at least for a few of his,
uh,
female readers in the 18th century.
And for many,
he's the,
the,
the very embodiment of,
of,
of oppressive patriarchy.
I mentioned earlier that,
um,
that it's Virginia Wolfe who's largely responsible for,
for our sense of Milton's identity as an oppressive patriarchal literary voice.
But Virginia Woolf too had,
had inherited these contradictory ways of thinking about Milton and about
Milton's Milton's power.
And you can see from the handout that in 1924,
what wolf is formulating,
beginning to formulate her,
her dazzling feminist critique of the masculine traditions,
what she thinks of as the masculine traditions of literary writing.
And she's not one of the,
she's not just one of the first literary critics to reveal that most famous
writers have been men.
Uh,
everyone had already had,
had always known that.
Um,
but she's one of the first literary critics to reveal that most famous writers
have been writing as men exerting the influence of their sex.
That's a,
that's to use her language in a manner that implicitly glorifies their
masculinity,
implicitly glorifies all men.
But this is not,
so she writes in 1924,
this is not so with Milton,
there's this,
and this is a,
this is a wolf,
a amazing argument here.
There's a small group of writers whose work,
and I'm quoting her,
whose work is pure uncontaminated sexless as the angels are said to be sexless
and Milton is their leader.
She tells us like Lady Mary Chadley Wolf holds up Milton as a powerful
authority.
He,
he's almost a mythological figure who can,
who can sanction,
who can authorize this revolution in women's writing that,
that Virginia Woolf is beginning to prophesied here early,
early in the 20th century.
But this of course,
as we know is this is only one of the ways in which Milton's power or what wolf
thinks of as his leadership can be thought of.
And in 1928 and this is the next quotation on the handout,
a Milton has come to represent for Virginia Woolf a very different type of
cultural force.
Uh,
near the conclusion of the perfectly extraordinary book.
A room of one's own,
a wolf elaborates on,
on her prophecy of a feminist future.
A world in which women can be viewed a literary feminist future,
a world in which women can be viewed as writers,
have no less stature and have no less power than men.
So this is,
uh,
this is wolf I'm quoting for my belief is,
and I'll,
I'll have to skip around a little bit for my belief is that if we live another
century or so and have 500 a year,
each of us in rooms of our own,
if we have the habit of freedom and the courage to write exactly what we think,
if we look past Milton's bogey for no human being should shut out the view,
then the opportunity will come in the dead poet who was Shakespeare's sister,
we'll put on the body,
which she has so often laid down now,
the,
the language is intentionally and really sublimely opaque and a apocalyptic here
as,
as wolf imagines,
what might have happened to Judith Shakespeare had she been given the cultural
opportunities of her more privileged brother William,
but the anticipated triumph of women writers can never occur according to
Virginia Woolf here until we look past Milton's bogey,
until we look past Milton's bogey.
And she's ingeniously vague about what Milton's bogey is.
And I've,
and I puzzled over this,
I puzzled over this phrase for years and I'm not,
I'm not even remotely satisfied that I have a clue what,
what,
what she means,
but Milton's bogey would seem to be,
I think that frightening shadow that Milton casts over wives who might find
themselves identifying with the subordinate.
Milton's,
uh,
Eve Milton's bogey seems to be the specter hovering over women poets are women
writers who may find in Milton and identification of poetic strength with
masculinity itself.
Now will,
it doesn't try to explain exactly how it is that Milton has shutting out the
view and she doesn't try to explain what the view would look like if it weren't
shut out,
but,
but inciting the power of what she claims to be.
This Puritan Bogey,
uh,
Virginia Woolf really subtly reveals,
I think how difficult it is even for her to shut out entirely the real,
or it might just be the bogus power of,
of John Melton at the very moment that will advise us women readers to look past
Milton's bogey.
She finds herself in a peculiar position of,
of echoing the poetry of John Milton.
And this is I think,
an unbelievable thing to have happen at one of the formative moments of,
of 20th century feminism.
She's alluding here,
I think,
to one of the most famous passages in paradise lost in which Milton is asserting
nothing other than his poetic power.
This is the,
this is a on the handout.
It might be on the reverse of the handout.
The,
the blind poet calls on the Holy Spirit to assist him,
assist him in the composition of the epic.
He asked the Heavenly Muse,
uh,
at the end of the passage to help him see and tell him things invisible to
mortals site.
And Milton is going to a need.
He'll,
he'll need this additional help from God because as he says,
this is near the middle of the passage because wisdom at one entrance is quite
shut out.
Milton's blindness,
the fact of his blindness has shut out his view of the visible world that would
ordinarily present itself to him through the entrance of his eyes.
And this,
this shutout will enable him,
will help him explore the invisible world of divine truth.
Now when Virginia Woolf writes that Milton's bogey has shut out the view of,
of his female readers,
she seems to be suggesting that the specter of Milton blinds women to the things
that they should be seeing the most important,
uh,
truths,
um,
out there in the world.
How troubling though this seems undeniable,
how strange that wolf really at her most radical is echoing the very words of
the power that she's opposing.
It's almost as if she were saying in some way in a post miltonic world,
which is the world that we all live in.
It's impossible fully to look past Milton's bogey that the rhetoric of power,
the literary strategies of power and in some cases the vary.
In some cases,
the very experience of power and of literary power have become inextricably tied
and indebted to Milton and his great prophecy of 20th century feminism.
Wolf is essentially proposing a cultural revolution.
And it's as if the text here,
we're telling us that whether we like it or not,
whether we like Milton or not,
the language of revolution is one that is forever and always indebted to that
boogey man John Milton as as Virginia Wolfe had written,
Milton is our leader.
Now,
some of you,
I'm assuming we'll,
we'll already have read,
uh,
we'll already have read paradise lost.
And so it will come to you as no surprise that the representation of power for
Wilton,
for which Milton is most celebrated is the power exhibited in the failed
revolution against God,
the revolution against God by,
by Satan and his fellow rebels.
And my guess is that our sense of Milton's power,
however,
that power is imagined,
is intimately related to the way in which Milton himself represents power in the
characters of,
of Satan and,
and of God in paradise lost.
So look at the,
look at the next passage.
This is from,
this is from Paradise Lost Satan and the,
and the rebel angels have been roundly defeated.
They'd been humiliated by the son of God.
And the other priggish loyalist angels.
So they are pained,
uh,
utterly humiliated there,
prostrate on the burning lake of this miserable new realm called hell.
Um,
and nonetheless,
Satan pulls himself together and begins to analyze to theorize his situation.
He describes for us his own power that somehow manages to survive even a
terrifying and humiliating defeat like the one he's just experienced.
So this is Satan.
What though the field be lost,
all is not lost.
The unconquerable will and study of revenge in mortal hate and courage never to
submit or yield.
And what does else not to overcome that glory never shall his wrath or might
extort for me to bow and sue for grace with supplement knee and deify his power,
who from the terror of this arm so late doubted his empire that were low indeed,
that we're in ignominy and shame beneath this downfall.
Now,
we might at first think that Satan's vaunting here is a product of nothing more,
nothing more elevated than,
than hate and a desire for revenge.
But Milton Milton's doing something truly extraordinary and,
and,
and I think that the imaginative achievement here in,
in St and speech is easy to miss.
Satan finds it ignominious and shameful to lower himself,
to God,
to bow and sue for grace with [inaudible] knee.
And deify has power.
But this kind of submission is,
is shameful.
Not because it's simply always shameful.
So to debase oneself,
it's an ignominious hasheme because it may very well be.
I think this is without question what Satan is implying here.
It may very well be that God is not actually omnipotent.
When an omnipotent would a truly all powerful God actually doubt the extent of
his own empire.
In,
in,
in Virginia,
Woolf's terms,
Satan is trying to look past God's bogey.
He tries to get behind the,
the highly theatrical,
the culturally constructed illusion of,
of God's power.
And it you,
you can hear Satan saying,
well,
so what if we lost?
The important thing is we may have lost this battle,
but the important thing is,
is that God revealed a terror of this arm,
of our strength,
a fear of the military,
strength of the rebel angels.
It's,
what's his,
what was manifest in this war?
God was so afraid of us that he actually doubted his hold on his own empire,
an empire that he was only actually able to maintain because of good luck or
something like superior military fire power,
but certainly nothing as grand and as absolute as omnipotence.
It's an amazing,
this is an amazing thing for Satan to say.
After his fall,
even the explosion of Satan from heaven was not sufficient to prove,
prove beyond a shadow of a doubt,
the legitimate authority of God,
that Satan is still able to doubt the legitimacy of Gods of God's power is a
testimony to the complexity.
I think of the,
of the analysis of,
of power and paradise lost.
No power,
not even God's power can be irresistibly and indisputably proven.
Satan refuses in this speech to deify the power of the conquering enemy.
And in this refusal,
Satan resembles no one so much as John Milton,
John Milton,
the political leftist who refused to deify the power of the English King Charles
the first,
um,
whom so many of his contemporaries considered to be God's anointed.
Um,
John Milton,
who wrote hundreds of pages of anti monarchic propaganda until King Charles,
his head was safely severed from,
from his body.
Like,
like Milton.
Satan is in the business of demystifying power,
of exposing political or cultural power is something that is not simply
inherently there or naturally.
Their power is something.
And this is what we learn from a reading of John Milton.
Power is something that is created by a human process of deification,
a process of,
of king worship or a process of God worship or book worship or a process for
that matter of,
of poet worship.
Now later on,
a paradise lost.
Satan comes to the conclusion that that old man and heaven who seemed,
uh,
who had assumed the authority to issue all of those arbitrary decrees,
Satan finally relents and concedes that he is actually an omnipotent God and
that,
that God actually is or was the omnipotent creator of all things.
But despite this enormous concession and this realization,
Satan is still justified,
I think in his cynical demystification of God's behavior before the defeat of
the rebel angels.
And Satan complains now that God never bothered to demonstrate to the angels
just how powerful he was.
And so this is the last quotation on the handout,
Satan again,
but he who reigns monarch in heaven till then as one secure sat on his throne
upheld by old repute,
consent or custom,
and his regal state put forth that fall,
but still his strength concealed which tempted our attempt and rot our fall.
Satan saying that before the war in heaven,
God's power just seemed like any other kings power as if God sat on the throne
of heaven merely because of the humor,
those humanly constructed reasons of of tradition or of old repute or cut
consent or custom.
Now,
alas for Satan,
it turned out that God's monarchy was actually based on genuine,
on genuine strength.
It wasn't simply that God just happened to be wearing the crown and just
happened to be sitting in the in the best chair.
But in Satan's articulation of what we can think of as a dialectic of power and
authority,
he provides us with a useful analysis of the problems besetting any
understanding of of power that the kinds of authority established by the bogeys
of tradition and custom and conservative tradition are not always
distinguishable from the kinds of authority that are based on genuine strength.
And even if we locate a source of some kind of genuine strength,
authoritative strength,
it's still usually possible as it is for Satan to argue that that power is
really a at base just the concealed product of customer.
What we would think of is cultural construction to be a king,
one need merely put forth one's regal state when simply needs to act king lane.
Now I raised the matter of say,
Satan's critique of God's power because the evaluation and the criticism of,
of Milton and especially in Milton's poetry has hinged for a couple of centuries
now on a related set of questions about the,
about this poet's power.
It is Milton,
is Milton powerful for the very straightforward reason that he's in possession
of this tremendous,
uh,
literary strength,
this unimaginable talent or,
or it as Milton only seen powerful because if the traditional religious values
with,
with which he is so intimately associated,
does Milton only seen powerful because he has the force or the strength or the
age old literary Canon behind him?
Does Milton only seen powerful because he's the very literary embodiment of
Patriarchy and,
and masculine bias.
Now,
I mean,
it goes without saying that these are questions that it's impossible for us to
try to answer.
Uh,
certainly now.
But Milton lets us know later in paradise lost,
okay,
that Satan was wrong to embark on his dangerous deconstruction of divine power.
Um,
Milton ultimately is a,
is a pious man and wants us to frown on Satan's critique of the Judeo Christian
conception of divinity.
But,
but Satan,
regardless of Milton's ultimate dismissal of Satan's position,
Satan's analysis of power and of God's power especially isn't that easily
dismissible.
And that's not simply because Satan bear such a strong resemblance to Milton as,
as of course he does.
Satan looks,
I'm convinced Satan looks ahead to us as,
as well.
Satan resembles us as readers as we attempt to dissect and to anatomize the
power of Milton's poetry.
And I go so far to say that,
um,
uh,
something like a satanic sensibility may be one of our best guides in our
reading of,
of Milton.
It's Milton Satan who best prepares us.
I'll throw this out here at the end of this lecture,
who best prepares us to explore what we can think of the law of as the
labyrinths of,
of miltonic power.
He puts us in a position to explore
that truly weird but undeniable process whereby the very word Milton,
the name Milton stops referring to a particular middleclass Londoner who was
born in 1608 and begins to embody the very essence of that strange and
inexplicably phenomenon that we call literary power.
Yeah.
So that's all I,
that's all of the content portion of this,
uh,
of this class.
The lecture is over.
Bet.
Let me remind you of a few things.
Um,
you must,
before you leave this,
uh,
this lecture hall,
put your name on one of the signup sheets.
Maybe I haven't hit well,
I'll find the sign up sheets and make sure that you have an opportunity to put
your name on them.
Um,
if you don't,
um,
it's possible that some of our unbelievably distinguished djs will find
themselves without a job.
And,
uh,
for next time,
um,
making sure that you will have read
at the very least,
Milton's great poem.
And he wrote,
he wrote it when he was only 21 years old.
Um,
the Ode on Christ's naitivity.
and,
and read,
of course,
the other two poems that are assigned for the class,
but we'll be focusing on what we call the naitivity out.
Okay.
That's it.